how do we find the cube of a number
really fast say we have to find the cube
of 12 the first thing we have to do is
observe the units and the tens digit of
the number that is being cubed the tens
digit is 1 and the unit's digit is 2
then we ask ourselves one question tens
digit multiplied by what will give us
the unit's digit yes what do we multiply
a one with to get a to we multiply it
with a two to get a to the tens digit
multiplied by two gives us the unit's
digit this number two is important we
will see why once this is done we write
the cube of the tens digit here that
will be one cubed in the second column
we multiply 1 cubed with this number so
we have one cubed multiplied by two in
the third column we multiplied this
product with this number again that
gives us 1 cubed multiplied by 2
multiplied by 2 and in the fourth and
the last column we multiply this product
with this number again we get this cube
of the tens digit multiply it with two
then multiply this with two and then
multiply this with two don't forget this
2 that we are multiplying the numbers
with is this 2 and not the unit's digit
for example if we have 2 cubed 26 we
would have 2 times 3 is equal to 6 the
cube of the tens digit could be 2 cubed
and then we could multiply with 3 and
then multiply again with 3 and so on so
not 6 now let's calculate these values 1
cubed is 1 1 cubed times 2 is 2 this
equals 4 and this will be 8 no this is
not a rancer once this is done we
multiply the second and the third column
numbers with 2 multiplying 2 with 2 will
give us 4 and multiplying 4 with 2 will
give us 8 these two numbers here will
always be 2 no matter what the number is
these two will
always be - in this technique we will
always multiply the numbers in the
second and the third columns with two
now we simply add the columns 8 4 plus 8
is 12 we write a 2 here and carry the 1
over 1 plus 2 plus 4 is 7 + 1 that's the
answer
12 cubed is 1728 let's go through it
quickly we first looked at the tens and
the unit's digits multiplying the tens
digit with two gave us the unit's digit
in the first column we wrote the cube of
the tens digit and continued multiplying
it with two till we reached the fourth
column then we multiplied the second and
the third column numbers with two and
then added each column how did we derive
this method we simply use the cube of a
binomial identity we have just modified
it a bit to get to the answer quickly
and easily now I want you to solve the
next example you may refer to this one
if you wish with the help of this
technique try calculating 14 cubed pause
the video take your time but do try
solving this ok let's look at the
solution what multiplied by the tens
digit will give us the unit's digit 1
multiplied by 4 will give us 4 we write
the cube of the tens digit first 1 cubed
will be 1 then we multiply it with this
number 1 multiplied by 4 will give us 4
multiplying this with 4 again will give
us 16 and multiplying this with 4 again
will give us 64 once we are done with 4
columns we multiply the numbers in the
second and the third columns with 2 4
times 2 is equal to 8 and 16 times 2 is
32 now we just add the numbers in each
column this is 64 so we write a 4 here
and carry the 6 over 6 plus 16 plus 32
is 54 we write 4
and carry the five over five plus four
plus eight is equal to 17 seven here and
carry the one over one plus one is two
fourteen cubed is 2744 does this work
for all numbers to know the answer
watch the second part of the session
where we will see a couple of more
examples
you
you